[Music]
what you're about to see hear and feel
are the memories of your ancestor who
has been dead for 500 years
you're past the Assassin's Creed
universe just seemed like something that
would lend itself very nicely to a
cinematic experience
we're really determined to make an
audience believe that this world and
these characters exists to have somebody
with Justin's strength and vision was a
huge bonus I want it to be an
unbelievable ride mixed with these
exotic worlds that n lead you into some
action sequences that are dynamic in the
Nira where there's a lot of CGI we
wanted to have as much old-school real
location shoots as possible so Spain
becomes a huge part of our film and
exoticness serves the assassins
when you put on the costume you really
feel like the character in terms of the
fighting for Aguilar these weapon of
choice with the blades on the wrist
we were very important for us to get the
parkour elements you know the fans are
going to be looking for those
he's gonna be really exciting
we are making the mystic experience we
work in the dark turn up the light
we are assassins
[Music]
you here to say whistle I understand
it's your birthday yeah the party's just
getting started
his name is Kellerman
we've traced his bloodline back 500
years to the Assassin's Creed how does
anyone in the world knows or cares you
no longer exist
[Music]
what is this place
this is your second chance
[Music]
for me your past you're about to enter
the Animus what you see hear and feel
are the memories of your ancestor who's
been dead for 500 years
wait a minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
what I saw it there and family
it was
you're watching you waiting to see who
you are
I believe you are destined to great
things that's fine now
we work in the dark just without the
lights
we are assassins
I'm beginning to like this
Altice unacceptable Michael
in the movie Michael Fassbender's
character is trapped and he has to chop
the leap of faith jumping 125 feet